[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing fantastic beasts 3 the
secrets of dumbledore yesterday was a
truly exciting day for the wizarding
world and its loyal fans as finally
finally a trailer dropped for long
anticipated fantastic piece film the
third installment of a potentially
five-part franchise has been pushed back
and back for years now so it's exciting
to see something finally coming to
fruition it's important to note however
that one of the reasons for the film
being pushed back besides the obvious
global crisis is that the screenplay
underwent a significant rewrite with jk
rowling bringing along former harry
potter screenplay writer and producer
steve cloves the trailer for the third
film was nothing short of impressive and
at least to me it certainly felt more in
line with the original films if you want
to see a breakdown of that trailer check
out the link in the pinned comment but
one thing that myself and fans were
quick to notice was the absence of a
certain character kathleen waterston aka
porpin tina goldstein
waterston who starred in the previous
two films fantastic beasts and where to
find them as well as fantastic peace the
crimes of grindelwald played an american
half-blood witch and aura working for
the magical congress of the united
states of america in the first two films
she's a main character and were given a
substantial portion of her backstory
like the fact that she attended
ilvermorny's school of witchcraft and
wizardry and the fact that she was
sorted into thunderbird house so it
seems peculiar she wouldn't make it into
the trailer for the third film
this also leaves one massive question is
she in the film at all or has she been
removed from the franchise well my
answer is this tina goldstein fans
should rest easy as porpentina is far
too intertwined into the story to be
removed altogether i can say this with
confidence for a few reasons first of
all queenie goldstein tina's sister is
still a massive part of the plot and
shows up in the trailer on several
occasions removing her sister for no
apparent reason would be a huge
continuity error and it just wouldn't
make sense i don't think they'd make
critical error like that second of all
fantastic beasts fans who are privy to
the harry potter law should already know
that tina eventually becomes the wife of
newt scamander who just so happens to be
the main character of the films we also
know that they go on to have children
removing her would be far too disruptive
to the film and harry potter canon it
would also invalidate the tension that
has been building between newt and tina
in the films released thus far lastly
catherine waterston who plays tina has
been credited for the role on imdb
yes yes imdb isn't the most reputable
source at times but along with these
other points i think i've made a fairly
convincing argument for why tina will be
in the films this leaves one more
question however why isn't tina in the
trailer i've got a few explanations for
this as well
first of all i want to say that the new
trailer introduces a lot of new concepts
actors and plot points by rewriting the
screenplay they've in a good way
reshaped the films that preceded this
one and i think that by removing
elements of old from the trailer they're
able to place more emphasis on the new
this means focusing on new creatures
placers and actors rather than the old
which unfortunately didn't get the
praise that warner bros were hoping for
this doesn't mean tina is a bad
character or actor it just means they're
trying to excite people with new
concepts
secondly i'd imagine that tina in the
secrets of dumbledore is off on her own
mission at the end of the crimes of
grindelwald we saw queenie tina's sister
joining the ranks of grindelwald's
followers i think that headstrong tina
would be off on a mission of her own to
track down and save her sister from the
likes of grindelwald what do you guys
think did you notice the absence of tina
where is she comment down below
until next time remember should things
at some point go terribly wrong it's
good to have a place to go you know for
a cup of tea
[Music]
you